jetzt im vis á vis von klaus ruhe madsen
dem parteilosen oberbürgermeister der
schönen stadt rostow er madsen sie haben
die kanzlerin auch verfolgt würden sie
sagen dass hatte war ein zeichen der
schwäche oder ein zeichen der stärke
ja auf jeden fall war es erst einmal
eine riesenüberraschung
ich stand in mein büro und habe an meine
uhr gemerkt dass es in der nachricht
gibt und die die kam aus dänemark und
dann habe ich ganz schnell deutsche
nachrichten nachgeschaut hat fernseher
angemacht und war ein wenig erschüttert
über der ausmaß der entschuldigung und
dachte eigentlich dass ich gerade der
rücktritt der kanzlerin gebe es also für
einen moment war ich ja gerade
frischwaren das hat mich doch bestürzt
ich fand das eine quasi etwas
übertriebene reaktion
ich glaube es hätte uns allemal gereicht
zu sagen wir haben uns das überlegt wir
haben das so festgelegt und es war nicht
richtig und das ändern wir jetzt und
dann hätte ich aber direkt danach auch
erwartet dass man mir sagt was machen
wir jetzt und da kam etwas was mich im
grunde genommen
doppelte ja wenn man dann sagt wir
müssen etwas machen und dann geht es
weiter
ich erwarte von einer führungskraft dass
er gesagt was wir machen also die
menschen brauchen einen fahrplan das ist
so ein bisschen wie sie stehen auf dem
warten auf den zug
das ist ja in ordnung wenn sie eine
durch teile bekommen dazu kommt in zwei
stunden da stellt sich der mensch darauf
ein dann warte ich halt zwei stunden
hole mir vielleicht ein café oder sowas
wenn ich aber da steht und es kommt gar
keinen oder der zug durch sein
willkommen nicht ich werde unsicher und
dann kommt irgendwann nur nicht auf
meinen gleich das ist ja auch miss nun
günstig und wenn wir einfach die
menschen sagen wir sind da dran
es ist aber im grunde darauf ein sie
haben es im grunde ja schon
vorweggenommen und längst verstanden die
bürgermeister sollen jetzt
offensichtlich das land retten
sie versuchen das in rostock mit einem
sogenannten modellprojekts sie haben
damit bisher sehr gute erfahrungen
gemacht da ist jetzt eine neue stufe
ausgerufen
aber sie haben auch mit einer steigenden
incidents zu kämpfen
das heißt das was vorgestern noch 31 war
ist heute schon bei 46 und man kann vom
wunderkind auch zum sorgenkind werden
sie in sachsen
wie groß ist ihre sorge
die sorge ist von tag 1 dabei ich glaube
jeder der was anders behaupten würde
wäre fehl am platze wir natürlich haben
wir uns jeden tag sorgen gemacht aber
auch wir haben immer wieder gesagt wir
werden einen weg mit corona finden
müssen wenn wir jetzt friseure
körpernahe dienste geschäfte schulen
kitas veranstaltungen ermöglichen das
leben zu lassen
dann müssen wir auch davon ausgehen dass
natürlich mit unserer infections lage
etwas passiert wir testen im großen stil
in unseren schulen da ist auch ein der
über die hälfte unserer heutigen positiv
meldungen stammen aus der schule also
wissen wir natürlich auch darum aber wir
haben ja auch immer gesagt das ist der
rostocker weg wissen generieren der
antwort auf das was sie bisher zu können
ja nicht sein dass wir das licht
ausmachen
ein stück weit ist es ja auch das mit
der lukb zu sagen ok wo waren die leute
wie waren sie jetzt wollen wir sehen
dass uns dort digitale nachverfolgung
auch möglich ist also das wie können wir
uns das system verbessern und das ist ja
doch das nachbeben die menschen
letztendlich rufen also halten sie eine
kerze hoch und geben sie die leute die
hoffnung pusten sie nicht diese gäste
aus und das fand ich diese woche ist mir
ein stück weit die kerzen ausgepustet
worden
und ich wünsche mir aber menschen die
vorne eine kerze hochhalten und das
wollen wir natürlich auf jeden fall in
rostock machen smudo kommen wir noch
apropos low carb herr müller was machen
wir eigentlich jetzt es ist verabredet
worden ja eine konsequente notbremse
einzusetzen mit dem adjektiv konsequent
und diese notbremse würde ja auch
bedeuten dass man beinahe hunderte
inzidenz die drei tage bleibt zurück auf
alles von vor dem siebten dritter geht
das wissen sie präziser als ich so jetzt
sagt tobias hans aus dem saarland dass
er ein fröhliches eröffnungskonzert
machen möchte sie sagen sie wollen
eigentlich auch nichts zurücknehmen von
dem was sie jetzt an lockerungen da
können sie gleich noch mal sagen was tun
wir jetzt eigentlich also erstmal muss
man sagen gerne in berlin noch gerne mal
die haben doch gar nicht alles umgesetzt
was die früheren mbps ermöglicht hätten
weil wir sehr vorsichtig sind und wir
wollen in ausgewählten pilotprojekten
praktisch den rostocker weg auch
nachvollziehen
und wollen sehen können wir in der
kultur im sport es sind neun projekte
von hunderten kultureinrichtungen können
wir da ein gefühl dafür bekommen wie
funktioniert es dass kontakt
nachverfolgen mit der app die wir jetzt
für berlin auch organisiert haben di
luca app mit abstand und hier gegen
regeln und testen vor ort dass sich
etwas tun muss bei meinen instanzen dass
ich wieder einschränken muss ist völlig
unstrittig die frage ist habe ich eine
chance es so klug zu machen und dinge
die jetzt im moment den menschen ein
bisschen freiheit geben
es ist so absichere mit einem harten
test regime dass ich mir diese freiheit
noch erhalte oder muss ich erkennen das
geht auf keinen fall auch nicht mit dem
testen und ich musste es wieder
zurückführen genau das diskutieren wir
jetzt in berlin
das ist die in der stadt die sorge aber
offensichtlich macht ja frau käßmann
mittlerweile nicht nur jede stadt
sondern auch jede jeder kreis und jedes
land nahezu etwas anderes wir haben
duisburg und dortmund verfolgt in
nordrhein westfalen andere beispiele gab
es aus brandenburg kann der bürger das
noch nachvollziehen
ich denke es inzwischen doch vielen
schwer weil du jedes mal schauen muss
was ist gerade wo eigentlich die regel
und dir das neu anschauen muss ich denke
aber auch unterschiede dürfen sein weil
wir haben ländliche gebiete wie
mecklenburg vorpommern in denen sicher
auch wieder sehr anders aussieht in
eigenen ring einzelnen regionen als in
berlin
also dass unterschiede sein dürfen ist
nicht so schlimm finde ich aber dass es
klarheit gibt wohin geht der weg
und da würde ich dem rostocker
oberbürgermeister recht geben wir
brauchen hoffnungszeichen und
hoffnungsschimmer
statt dieser lähmung die alle im moment
wirklich auch krank macht und ich denke
dass bei aller angst vor dem virus und
allen präsident zahlen und instanzen die
wir sehen müssen die menschen auch eine
gewisse bewegungsfreiheit haben ich
mache mir um viele sorgen die psychisch
schwer belastet sind ich mache mir
gerade auch um kinder sorgen die jetzt
schon wieder nicht in kitas gehen können
in schulen gehen können wenn tests
überall denn mal da wären dann sähe die
lage ganz anders aus weil das erlebe ich
war selbst auch bei bestimmten
veranstaltungen dann getestet ist dann
bist du selber aus sicherer du steckst
niemanden an und niemand steckt dich an
also das muss einfach viel viel
schneller vorwärts gehen ich denke
darauf warten alle auf tests und auf
impfungen ok 219 landkreise von 412 sind
mittlerweile herr lauterbach über 100
incidents auch an sie die frage
konsequente notbremse
die aber eigentlich niemand macht das
heißt im grunde würden sie sagen bei
diesen landkreisen müsste es schon eine
ausgangssperre gibt ja das ist meine
position
das muss ich ehrlich sagen also das muss
ja auch teil einer gesamtstrategie
gesamtstrategie die ich empfehlen würde
wäre das wir jetzt noch mal zwei wochen
lang also die notbremse wirklich
durchziehen auch keine lockerung auch
keine modellprojekte wir brauchen hier
nicht wie bei jugend forscht
auszuprobieren was ich mir dann depart
ass also hinbekommen soll wie weit ich
gehen kann bevor mir das alles
kollabiert das ist auch in tübingen
beispielsweise so dass das alles nur
nobel aber die fallzahlen steigen
die idee dass man durch viel testen die
dritte welle beherrscht das geht
natürlich nicht somit die erste phase
müsste wirklich nochmal locker und sagen
das ist unpopulär das zu sagen aber das
haben die haben dann auch nicht
geschafft bei 117 ist so viel
ansteckender was ich einfach die frage
also sich wie herr wiler wir warten
entweder ab und werden diesen lockdown
dadurch später bekommen dann wird aber
länger gelten
oder kommt und dann kann man wenn man
das in den griff bekommen und haben eben
kein besseres ergebnis aber wenn man ich
bin nur die nase also wenn man den
doktor gemacht hat und man ist aus dem
exponentiellen wachstum nochmal raus
dann können solche modelle gemacht
werden dann kann ich auch durch die
testung in den betrieben und in den
schulen kann ich das stabilisieren aber
es wie bei einem patienten ich kann den
patienten erst sagen wir mal ich kann
erst bei entwicklungsprogramme machen
oder ich kann sagen wir jemanden der
beatmet worden ist also nimmt den kann
ich enthüllen und von der
beatmungsmaschine aber muss erst einmal
stabil sein und derzeit ist der
patienten nicht stabil
wir sind in einer komplett und stabilen
lage und das muss erstmal abgefangen
werden
und da das werden wir ohne einen locker
nicht aber ist diese lage nicht auch
politisch gemacht weil ich sagen wir
gerade wenn wir es auch nochmal in
berlin bleiben also auch die
kassenärztliche vereinigung dass die
beispielsweise jetzt den vertrag
aufgekündigt hat mit dem mit dem senat
obwohl wir diese im 10
wir brauchen gerade für biontech weil
sozusagen dieses zentren dafür auch die
voraussetzungen sind oder das ganze
drama um astra zenica beispielsweise das
über 600.000 berliner sich gerade nicht
impfen lassen
da stellt sich für mich hat sich die
schuldfrage die wird auf beiden seiten
vorhanden sein aber was mich dass für
einen esefeld kampagne gewesen sein dass
es uns sozusagen nicht gelingt menschen
davon zu überzeugen obwohl die
weltgesundheitsorganisation und auch die
ärzteverbände sagen dass der impfstoff
unbedenklich ist dass das nicht gelingt
weil es ist nun wirklich nicht richtig
ich habe selbst mit dem präsidenten der
kv gesprochen und die haben einen
vertrag aus formalen gründen auch
erstmals angekündigt der mitte sich
nicht immer weiter verlängert die sind
an bord
es hat nicht eigene plagen auch an bord
einen tag stillstand in einem berliner
im zentrum gegeben
wir haben eine gute impfquote deutlich
über dem bundesdurchschnitt und es sei
also über 600.000 und kleider sind sie
an technik schaden wurden nochmal bei
astrazeneca gibt es natürlich ein
problem was kein ministerpräsident zu
verantworten hat es gibt durch das hin
und her bei diesem impfstoff natürlich
ein misstrauen es war eine frage und wir
versuchen jetzt alle aufzuklären wir
laden mehr ein als wir eigentlich an
impfstoff zur verfügung haben damit es
auch gut voran geht und es gibt auch
wieder mehr zustimmung wir hatten heute
alleine 5000 impfung mit astrazeneca
also die haare nicht noch mehr gas geben
also auch bei der ems reihenfolge dass
er ja sie haben recht aber doch dann
wenn ich mehr impfstoff habe also gab es
noch ist doch da der witterung nein er
liegt nicht um frau illner sondern wir
haben 160 1000 impfdosen von astra
bekommen und davon sind 130 tausend
verimpft oder vergeben an die
krankenhäuser zum beispiel oder für die
40.000 lehrerinnen und lehrer die jetzt
in den nächsten tagen geimpft werden man
kann nicht sagen es liegen 600.000
impfdosen rund 160000 überhaupt
geliefert wo ich habe von den 600.000
berlin angesprochen die mir ins
benachrichtigung bekommen ja und das
dauer nicht haben impfen lass mir ist
dauert doch natürlich wenn ich ab morgen
80 millionen impfdosen hätte für jeden
bundesbürger würde ist monate dauern bis
die verhilft sind und natürlich laden
wir viele menschen ein
hier ist in den nächsten wochen manche
kommen in einer woche manche kommenden
drei wochen wollen sich gar nicht mit
astrazeneca impfen lassen das gehört
doch zu bewegen zusammen
auf der anderen seite darüber aufregen
dass millionen von impfdosen in italien
gefunden worden sind aber eigentlich
mehr sagen auch brachten und sich immer
dass wir da kann ich nun auch nicht
sondern ein gift oder du hast würde ich
sagen aber dass wir hier noch 130 länder
wo noch nichts geworden ist und dann
haben wir diese situation aber das land
so logik werden muss mehr machen können
auch deswegen bieten wir immer mehr die
haus und die betriebsärzte ein weil die
in einer ganz anderen beratungssituation
und auch in einem anderen
vertrauensverhältnis mit den patienten
viel besser
natürlich sagen können nimmt es der
impfstoff hilft er hilft sogar nach der
ersten impfung vielleicht sogar besser
als andere
genau das schon vor wochen in dieser
sendung gesagt wir müssen aber unbedingt
danke für diesen einschub wir müssen
unbedingt noch mal auf eine zentrale
frage kommen nämlich herzen würden sie
denn auch sagen ab einer bestimmten
incidents klar können sie auch dieses
modell nicht mehr weiter fahren und dann
ist es eine gute überlegung zu sagen wir
schicken die menschen nach hause in
portugal und großbritannien funktioniert
das also es ist er erstmal will ich ja
tatsächlich geld mehr aufhören lautet
einmal reagieren erstens ist es so dass
man im leben niemals nie sagen sollte
und es können immer situationen
entstehen indem man oder als
intelligenter mensch seine meinung
revidiert immer noch möchte ich aber
eins anmerken und das ist doch genau das
was ich die ganze zeit versuche zu sagen
wir brauchen angebote statt verbote oder
gehe ich habe das gefühl dass wir diese
pandemie ein stück weit aus der
verwaltung sicht der regierung sicht
versuchen im griff zu kriegen sind viel
stärker aussehen der menschen wenn ich
höre machen fünf tage also das war das
was ich dachte wir machen 50 ostern zu
okay was würden denn die meisten
menschen setzen wir machen nicht nur
einen arbeitsplatz zu
die geschäfte zu sondern auch den zug
also bitte bleiben sie zu hause setzen
sie sich auch hier sofort gucken sie
sich die decke ab jetzt überlegen wenn
man ehrlich für uns jeder für uns dass
wir jetzt die regierungs ansage was
machen wir denn dann also überlegen mir
für einen moment das ist ein sehr gute
idee ich setze mich jetzt 15 auf dem
sofa cook die decke an oder überlege ich
was kann ich machen az zum park ist das
ist alles ist zu ich glaube ich gehe zu
meinen nachbarn und wir trinken ein glas
wein und vielleicht trinken auch eine
flasche wein und da morgen ja ohnehin
auch frei ist können auch gleich eine
kiste wein trinken
und jetzt müssen wir uns ja dann
überlegen wo genau ist bisher uns
erkenntnis gekommen wo war die infektion
am stärksten
wir haben den reglementierten und guten
arbeitsplatz wir haben alle anderen orte
mit gutem service platz und nun haben
wir das problem auf einmal menschen
treffen sich privat menschen sind wie
wasser die suchen sich ihren weg und das
finde ich ein extrem wichtiger wir sind
doch land der denker und lenker und
jetzt auf einmal der schließer und
henker also das ist doch würden wir
vernichten
doch die hoffnungen die geschäfte die
die das existenz von wie viele
menschenleben gerettet wir auch solche
maßnahmen wir haben aber kein incidents
darüber wie es den menschen geht mit den
kindern geht es den firmen
es ist mir zu einseitig einfach zu sagen
nein lockt damit ist die antwort hat das
ist letztlich das ist dann zwischenfall
wir sind jetzt in einer situation
gekommen wo wir das vorübergehend noch
mal brauchen und ich stimme zu dass wir
den menschen zu wenig zutrauen kommen
auch genau zu dem umgekehrten schluss
ich bin ganz sicher wenn wir den
menschen erklären würden wir müssen
jetzt mal 14 tage die privaten kontakte
stark herunterfahren und demnächst
müssen wir die betriebe sicherer machen
das versteht die leute und sagen wie das
mache ich mit das klappt und ich glaube
dass die leute auch so dumm dich sind
dass sie sagen okay ich darf nicht ins
restaurant
aber zu hause da habe ich mich mit zehn
leuten treffen dann feiern werden und
lassen uns was bringen zudem sind die
leute nicht aber es muss eine klare
ansage sein und ich glaube auch dass wir
zum teil die bürger wie kinder behandelt
nach dem motto wir können euch das jetzt
sind nicht zumuten nicht schlechte
nachricht kann nicht zugemutet werden
die leute verstehen die wollen aber dann
auch sicherheit dass das auch wirkt die
wollen dann eine klare rechnung so lange
brauchen das haben wir den jetzt zwölf
monate vorgelegt das ist nicht immer
gefragt wir machen das nach reisen
das ist aber wir sehen auch schon im
netz nur noch drei lok reinach aber
nicht mehr sehen ich will mich erst ein
bisschen genutzten noch dann den leuten
und weil der lok dann schlecht gerätes
nicht michael müller das gerade richtig
zwischen geworfen also muss auch zu dem
stehen was man gemacht hat die lok bei
uns in europa haben mit sicherheit sehr
vielen millionen menschen das leben
gerettet und von dem was wir in
deutschland wissen von
modellierung vom imperial college of
london haben wir mit den locken bisher
gemacht haben mögen nicht das
intelligenteste mittel gewesen sagen sie
haben wir gewählt haben wir 500.000
menschen das leben gerettet
500.000 menschen geistig sagen das war
bisher alles mist nicht die fdp höre
oder sage ich das sind verfahren aus dem
mittelalter und so weiter und so fort
aber die jeweils hat uns waren sehr lang
herr lauterbach sie waren länger eben
unserem land im vergleich zu anderen
ländern
und wir haben immer falsche daten gesagt
wir haben immer gesagt die politik das
dauert jetzt drei wochen neu
dazugekommen also wenn wir wenn wir die
mutation b17 flächendeckend hier nicht
bekommen hätten dann wären wir quasi
durch die großen wellen durch war mit
der alten variante wäre jetzt an enormer
effekt durch das gute wetter gekommen
aber das ist mutationen gibt der waren
sie doch der erste der dies sagt genau
welcher werden können wenn man sie auch
der erste der natürlich aber ich kann
darum nicht sagen also dass wir quasi
also das dass wir quasi in dieser
situation gestolpert sind ich hab das ja
ich habe es ja kommen gesehen dass das
hier rüber kommt sehr früh war ich nicht
der einzige ich betone immer ich nehme
mich sehr eng mit anderen
wissenschaftler hat michael hermann
rottmann christian drosten so dass hier
nicht der eindruck entsteht ich hätte
was gesehen was wir nicht gesehen habe
aber wir sagen das wird kommen das ist
nicht mehr kippt das war schon also vor
eben auch wahr dass gott die leute haben
sich ja damals schon verdient daran dass
einfach folgendes gemacht worden
dann haben wir da gab es die
wissenschaftler die haben gesagt wir
sagen dass jetzt der bevölkerung die
machen halt lockdown und so dann wirkt
das sehr gut wann gemacht früh wie in
der medizin niemand da gab es aber sehr
viele politiker haben gesagt nein wir
sind noch nicht soweit vielleicht kommt
es nicht so dick vielleicht geht es
nochmal weg von allein
und vielleicht müssten die bevölkerung
die bevölkerung erst mal sehen dass es
wirklich so ansteckend ist
somit mussten wir erstmal die zahlen
steigen lassen um überhaupt die politik
begründen zu können die von anfang an
früher viel besser bewertet aber was
wirklich weiß gut ist ja dass das wir
immer noch vom lockdown reden während in
anderen ländern einfach durch geimpft
wird und wir haben
wir haben den bekannterweise nicht und
trotzdem glaube ich dass es sinn macht
sich darauf zu konzentrieren und sich
die best practice beispiele zu holen
entschuldigung aber es ist ja im grunde
über diesen mangel den impfstoff haben
wir hier natürlich auch schon viel
geredet es ist ja jetzt noch absurder
dass offensichtlich die politik die
menschen nach mallorca schickt und dann
hinterher feststellt dass die ihr
eigentlich auch getestet werden müssen
wenn sie dahin fliegen und wieder zurück
kommen soll
also es wird ja noch verrückter wir
lassen ja dinge zu die wir schon kennen
und von denen wir auch schon wissen dass
sie eine gefahr bergen und ins feld dann
wieder zu spät ein dass wir eigentlich
auch diese urlauber lieber hier behalten
sollten und nicht nach mallorca schicken
sollte nicht das kann man dann wirklich
keinen mehr vermitteln und externen und
auch nicht nach calais kann man das mehr
erklären
es ist viel gefährlicher ist in
mecklenburg vorpommern als mecklenburg
vorpommern unterwegs zu sein als nach
mallorca zu fliegen
also das ist jetzt natürlich die nächste
die nächste frage das ist ein riesen
dilemma
mallorca das ist einfach nicht
nachvollziehbar haben wir doch einfach
mal im moment sich hinsetzen und sagen
wie würden sie jetzt ihr nachbar das
erklären wenn sie gleich die so gesagt
die bundeskanzlerin herzen sie würde
himmel und hölle in bewegung setzen dass
eigentlich diese reisen ins ausland
untersagt werden weil auch auf mallorca
mittlerweile p1 eine noch viel
gefährlichere mutante unterwegs ist so
arbeiter sprechen dann das
justizministerium und wahrscheinlich
irgendwie auch noch der außenminister
dagegen und sagen dadurch musste jedoch
angebote machen machen sie doch das
rätsel in warnemünde auf dann brauchen
die leute schließen sie ein oder sie
fliegen aber die werden ja zusätzlich
geflogen über die mallorca hat jetzt
also bestritten die haben jetzt
bestritten dass die p1 haben ja okay da
gibt es also um das klar zu machen ich
glaube das übrigens nicht also ich
glaube dass dort b1 ist aber es gibt
quasi und brasilien zwei monaten es gibt
bei 1.128 und da gibt es b11 28.11 ist
das punkt 1 und vorher war es klar das
war pelé einst und jetzt ist es
plötzlich das ist die ursprungs feiern
den brasilien aus der p1 entstanden ist
das heißt da wird auch noch getrickst
ich glaube da kein wort ich glaube dass
die mittlerweile längst b 1
und ich glaube auch den fallzahlen ich
daher haben wir gekämpft da glaube ich
war wieder schulter an schulter wir
haben wirklich nach hilfs konstrukten
also gesucht das irgendwie zu verbieten
weil das kann ich niemandem erklären
dass auf mallorca gefeiert wird mit
einer möglicherweise nicht zutreffenden
also incident und dort gelten die regeln
nicht und jung kann die leute nicht das
kann nicht erklärt hat dass nicht mehr
getestet und es wird nicht mal getestet
richtig weil das ist ja die nächste
frage wer überprüft dann eigentlich die
garantien andy die urlauber sollen
maximal die reformationszeit die ist ja
auch nicht genau in dem moment in die
leute zurück frau käßmann ich würde
gerne auch mal fragen wenn ich das
dazwischen tragen darf wenn jetzt gesagt
wird
die urlauber werden getestet bevor sie
zurück fliegen ja dürfen sie denn dann
wenn sie positiv getestet sind in ein
flugzeug steigen wo sechs reihen
auseinandersetzen und dann das ganze
flugzeug mit infiziert wird oder bleiben
sie dann zwei weitere wochen in einem
hotel auf mallorca ich habe einen
kollegen der aus bangkok beispielsweise
der ist hierher geflogen weil seine
mutter im sterben lag der ist in
deutschland eingereist ohne test und
konnte dann später als er nach bangkok
ist direkt musste er vom flughafen in
ein hotelzimmer dass er zwei wochen
nicht verlassen durfte das habe ich auch
schon nicht verstanden also das ganze
prinzip wenn ich teste darf dieser
mensch denn wenn er positiv getestet das
in ein flugzeug und dann erst in
deutschland in quarantäne
oder muss er dann nicht vor ort bleiben
also das ist doch auch nicht zu ende
gedacht und vor allen dingen muss ich
sagen man kann es den menschen nicht
erklären die sich hier gut an die regeln
halten und dann noch nicht mal eine
ferienwohnung fahren dürfen das habe ich
vorhin schon gesagt das ist nicht mehr
vermittelbar und ich finde er laut aber
auch das muss die politik sich auch und
herr müller auch anhören dass viele auch
durch das impfen das hat eben gesagt
durch das mangelnde impfen durch die
nicht vorhandenen tests sind die leute
mürbe und sagen warum passiert nichts es
passiert nicht wir haben am anfang
gehört also weihnachten wenn wir uns
alle zusammenreißen und dann ist
weihnachten alles in ordnung dann hieß
es wahrscheinlich schaffen wir es bis
ostern
und jetzt heißt es wir brauchen einen
neuen lockdown dass das macht die
menschen ja hoffnungslos und wer keine
hoffnung hat dass ich irgendetwas ändert
dahinter steckt er dann auch irgendwann
renitent käßmann dahinter steckt ja
jetzt auch eine gefahr und die frage ist
tatsächlich schafft man es
auch die menschen zu überzeugen wenn man
schon so oft an ihr verständnis und ihre
vernunft appelliert hat und viele
verhalten sich natürlich auch weiter
hoffentlich vernünftig es war
interessant zu sehen dass auch beide
kirchen bei der christlichen kirchen
gegen dieses gottesdienst verbot
protestiert haben also auch da wurde
unwillen und protest eingelegt fühlen
sich die gläubigen ihren glauben
verpflichtet oder der politik was würde
jetzt die theologin sei jetzt müssen wir
erstmal sagen im vergangenen jahr wurden
gottesdienste verboten das war für die
christen im land hinter das sind unsere
höchster fest ca freitag ostersonntag
damals gab es aber noch keinerlei
konzepte vor einem jahr es gab keine
masken die zur verfügung waren es gab
keine hygiene konzepte wir wussten wenig
über das virus in den letzten monaten
haben die kirchen das eingeübt mit
abstand in verantwortlichen konzepten
wie es übrigens will ich sagen gleich
weil das argument dann immer kommt in
theater und opern dass beispielsweise
auch was solche gottes dies in den nicht
gesungen werden in den riesigen räumen
oder sogar open air ein gottesdienst
gefeiert wird kurz viel kürzer als sonst
auch diese verantwortbar viele davon
erlebt und mit gefeiert und deshalb ist
auch dieser dieser widerspruch bei den
kirchen da sie waren völlig überrascht
von dieser bitte der politik aber
digitale gottesdienste gibt es natürlich
auch das haben wir inzwischen wirklich
sehr gut eingeübt freikirchen lassen
sich das singen und das beten gar nicht
verbieten
das führt auch immer wieder zu
ansteckungen und auch sein sie haben ein
anderes problem das muss ich sagen zu
den algerier das schlecht dass
freikirchen
ja bei kirchen dazu super beider events
geworden sind aber dennoch gelang fühlen
sich wenigstens nicht alleingelassen
wissen sie ein christ der in ein
gotteshaus kommen darf um auch seine
angst vor gott zu bringen
in dieser zeit in der vieles so
belastend sind das belastend ist das
habe ich erlebt was dass menschen auch
bedeutet viele ältere die unendlich
einsam sind diese halbe
dreiviertelstunde am sonntag zu haben
mit allen vorsichtsmaßnahmen
das ist trost das tut gut das ist
übrigens auch lebensmittel
lebensmittelläden sind auch offen für
viele menschen ist das immens wichtig
dass können sich manche vielleicht
überhaupt nicht vorstellen und gerade
auch an ostern aber es wird
verantwortlich gehandhabt ich war oft
genug in kirchen um das auch so sagen zu
können
diesen tag vermissen sie tatsächlich das
denken daran dass der mensch nicht nur
ein virus weiter gäbe ist absolut also
ich finde dass der wiederwahl
wiederaufbau von menschen der emotionale
überhaupt nicht stattfindet und ich
finde es deswegen so schade weil das
eine ganz starke bindungskraft hat die
wir verschenken und das tut mir weh und
ich glaube das tut vielen deutschen w
ich glaube das hat auch was mit einer
nationalen identitätskrise sogar zu tun
nicht erinnern made in germany und made
in germany steht für exzellenz steht
dafür dass dinge laufen und wenn das
plötzlich nicht mehr klappt dann geht
das auch als kollektive urvertrauen und
ich sage mal hätte hätte fahrradkette
aber die ganze nummer um die impf
beschaffung auf war ja ein einziger ja
german angst tritt bis hin zu european
angst auch was die beschaffungs
richtlinien anging für die die eu ja
auch mitverantwortlich ist wenn man da
ein bisschen mutiger gewesen wäre
da geht es keineswegs um germany first
aber zumindest ein verantwortungsvolles
deutschland was vielleicht doppelt so
viel eingekauft hätte und gesagt hätte
die hälfte für uns und die hälfte für
die drittländer beispielsweise und ich
glaube das geht viel mehr an den
solarplexus als sich viele bewusst
machen und dass der einzelne mensch
überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt sollte
und ich sag noch mal 82 millionen
deutsche sind akteure
sie könnten teil davon sein wenn ich mir
die neuseeländische präsidentin angucke
die von ihrem team redet ja und damit
meint sie sozusagen
die bundesbürger das funktioniert hier
nicht und das ist so ein starkes
narrativ unserer mut republik was wir
leider leider liegen lassen und
verschenken und mit verheerenden folgen
wohlgemerkt gerade angesprochen
diese spaltung der gesellschaft ist ja
das gefährlichste was es gibt gerade
auch was dient das vertrauen angeht in
den rechtsstaat in die demokratie und
ich bin eine überzeugte demokraten und
ich sage es nochmal es tut mir weh und
ich glaube es gibt viele menschen da
draußen den das weh tut weil wir wissen
dass wir es besser können und der fehlt
der magnetismus
da fehlt die agilität der um kreativität
ja und nun her ist er bisher spielte er
ist das beste beispiel dafür
aber die muss man gewähren lassen auch
auf lokaler ebene man muss diese gras
gut bewegung auch zulassen wird
die darf man sozusagen nicht mit
bürokratie wieder erdrücken und das
passiert leider sie sind zufrieden da
oberbürgermeisters gibt auch viele die
unzufrieden sind heute ist ausruhe
madsen erwähnt wurden von keiner
geringeren als der bundeskanzlerin
schauen sie mal funktioniert es ja es
ist keinem oberbürgermeister und keinem
landrat verwehrt das zu tun was in
tübingen und rostock getan wird
alle können das macht und der besitz
immer unterstützend tätig sein
alle können das machen was sie in
rostock machen herzen hätten sie diesen
satz gerne ein bisschen früher gehört
bin hätte ich sehr sehr gerne früher
gehört hatte ich vielleicht ein wenig
weniger draht gehabt ja sie müssen ganz
schön kämpfen und sie waren ganz schön
wie lange erleiden oder ziemlich oft und
ziemlich viel und die das ist natürlich
trotzdem ein großes ein großes lob an
die rostockerinnen und rostocker wie wir
gemeinsam diesen weg gegangen sind und
deswegen habe ich mich darüber natürlich
für meinen bürgerinnen und auch für
mainz verpasste freue mich trotzdem
loswerden ich glaube nämlich dass der
essenz ein bisschen nicht erkenne sie
haben ein problem und sie kommen eine
lösung und aus diese lösung macht
jemanden zehn weitere probleme oder
bedenken dann müssen sie finden sie noch
mal zehn lösungen und dann haben sie 100
probleme und bedenken
und dann denken sie sich irgendwann
vielleicht bleibe ich lieber bei meinen
ersten problem das war einfacher und
lassen es liegen das ist das problem
deutschland ist ein riesentanker
geworden den müssen wir ganz schnell im
hafen bringen und daraus ein schnellboot
machen wir müssen wirklich agiler werden
die welt verändert sich ein virus
verändert sich und wir sind viel zu
stark präsentierte sich als
bürgermeister versuchen etwas umzusetzen
irgendwas zu errichten hat genau das
sehen neu ausschreiben und genau dann
sagen alle also das geht beim besten
willen nicht aber wir müssen doch dass
das nein also sie haben nur ablehnung
wie viel energie braucht ein mensch dann
um seinen guten idee umzusetzen
die bundesregierung wenn sie es schon
schaffen wir unterstützen das dann geben
sie mir doch die möglichkeit zu sagen
morgen brauche ich dort ein zelt hier
die leute machen die test und so wird
das ausgeführt lassen sie uns doch
einfluss rein bekommen damit wir was
ausprobieren können also wir brauchen
vom rostocker plan geschrieben war
bis der durch land boden irgendwo also
bis sie überhaupt ein wenig akzeptanz
dann haben sie so viel zeit verloren in
ein pandemie das ist verheerend und da
wünsche ich mir wirklich ein bisschen
mehr mut zeigen modellrechnungen macht
mal modellregion das muss schneller
gehen vielleicht gucken wir uns jetzt
aber tatsächlich mal an wir sind im
zehnten monat 11 monat dieser pandemie
momentan gibt es eine menge
pilotprojekte und 100
endlich wieder jubeln in rostock
funktioniert das hunderte zuschauer im
stadion alle getestet vor dem spiel die
sieben tage incidents 45,9 so niedrig
wie sonst kaum in deutschland endlich
wieder ins konzert
die berliner philharmoniker spielen vor
besuchern alle tragen masken alle haben
sich vor dem konzert testen lassen
was wir hier zeigen ist dass man zu
sagen mit guter hygiene konzept
zuzüglich testende veranstaltung
durchführen kann und auch shoppen geht
tübingen testet einfach jeden der in die
innenstadt will ist der test negativ
gibt es ein tagesticket modellprojekte
für mehr normalität warum geht das nicht
überall in deutschland so herr müller
also wir haben es jetzt angesprochen wir
wünschten uns mehr tests wir wünschen
uns natürlich mehr impfen und wir
wünschen uns mehr modellprojekte jetzt
gibt es die aber was machen wir daraus
wird das tatsächlich jetzt so sein dass
jedes jede stadt jeder landkreis jeder
einzelne bürgermeister sein einzelnes
projekt erfinden und ich glaube das kann
man nicht pauschal entscheiden sondern
das kann man nur an der sache und an der
situation vor ort dann auch entscheidend
was geht und was nicht geht aber auch
überrascht dass die bundeskanzlerin
heute tübingen und rostock
so habe es auch erst jetzt bei ihm
mitbekommen leider ist air berlin nicht
noch mit dazu eingefallen
aber aber aber dieses ganze dilemma der
situation wird ja in unserer runde schon
deutlich wir freuen uns über die
modellprojekte und werden ja auch
ermuntert es zu machen herr droste num
unter die kanzlerin ermuntert auch
mächtig und gleichzeitig staunen wir
darüber dass auf einmal das saarland
aber modell bundesland werden will
die wissenschaft aus gutem grund mit
wasser expertise sagt um gottes willen
auch modellprojekte sind lockerung die
euch im moment gar nicht leisten können
soll und dass es gibt auch nicht im
übrigen die bevölkerung die das will
sondern es gibt 100 verschiedene
meinungen in der bevölkerung sollen ab
sie wird schaffte was ganz anderes als
die familie und die lehrer wollen was
anderes als die ärzte und das ist das
dilemma im moment der politik dass wir
uns immer bemühen über 1 ausgleich und
eine gratwanderung versuchen möglichst
vielen gerecht zu werden man das führt
dann genau zu den situationen die karl
lauterbach zu recht kritisiert dass es
zum schluss dann möglicherweise nichts
halbes und nichts ganzes ist aber es ist
aus einem besten anspruch heraus weil es
eben nicht so einfach ist diese schwarz
und weiß das funktioniert vielleicht
auch in der panne
im funktion nicht wir haben sie haben
vom letzten gefecht gesprochen in dieser
dritten welle herr lauterbach würden sie
denn immer noch sagen auch im angesicht
von den modellen und den versuchen vor
allen dingen wie dem zu mir wissen zu
kommen zu wissen wo sich menschen
anstecken in welchen konstellationen sie
sich anstecken ihnen eben mit dem frei
testen auch wieder leben möglich zu
machen würden sie immer noch sagen das
ist ein letztes gefecht in das wir
demoralisiert und ohne die richtigen
waffen ziehen
demoralisiert müsse nicht 13 also man
muss mit einer klaren strategien dieses
letzte gefälscht das wird das schwerste
gefecht werden und zwar deshalb weil die
fallzahlen die wir jetzt erwarten müssen
die werden zum schluss noch höher sein
als die fallzahlen in der zweiten welle
die ja schwerer war als erster werden
und das ist diesmal anders sein eine
besonderheit ist trifft sehr viele
kinder
das trifft sehr viele jüngere leute und
wir müssen bei zehn prozent der
infizierten mit einem langen verlauf
rechnen wo wir auch nicht jetzt sagen
können ob der tatsächlich sich danach
wieder selbst heilt das heißt wir haben
hier also eine welle von chronisch
kranken menschen vor uns die in diese
bälle reingehen und sich nicht
vorstellen können dass sie nachher
keiner krankheit haben die sie nicht
loswerden
daher wird die welle harter das ist
jetzt nicht demoralisieren sondern eine
epidemiologie es gibt leute die haben
große sorge davor dass es und jetzt wie
kann man da rangehen auf keinen fall in
dem man sich an der illusion hingibt und
die illusion wäre das ist eine welle wie
wir sie mit der alten mutter in der
alten mutation gekannt haben das ist
anders das ist jetzt die kinder werden
sehr viel härter rangenommen
die mittleren altersgruppen während
ihren verschlägen erkrankt und daher
hätte ich jetzt ein klares signal
gegeben lockerungen auch modellprojekte
später aber erstmal kontrolle
reinbringen will denn wenn ich jetzt
etwas sage was ich alles sagen muss das
ist ganz schlimm was kommt jetzt bitter
die fallzahlen gehen hoch also christian
drosten rechnet bis mit bis zu 100.000
fällen pro tag das glaube ich nicht
aber also sind hier durchaus 30 40 50
tausend fälle pro tag denkbar
es gibt auch kollegen herrn professor
nagel der rechnet mit einer 2000
die dance mit 2000 und wenn ich diesen
botschaft geben muss da kann ich gleich
sagen wir lockern an einigen es
wirtschaftlich sagen denn ich kann nicht
gleich selbst wenn die lockerungen in
einigen städten funktionieren wenn ich
das signal jetzt gebe wir machen überall
modelle und lockern
dann kriege ich die leute nicht zu der
vorsicht die jetzt aber dringend
notwendig ist
wir machen das ja nicht für uns in der
politik sondern machen das wirklich um
die bevölkerung zu schützen
jetzt kommt noch mal ein sehr schweres
letztes gefecht und im sommer haben was
dann geschah